well the media insists that the right is
to blame for politicizing this pandemic
they continue to insist that those
pushing for reopening are inherently
deplorable president Trump moves to cut
off green cards and bill de blasio finds
out that criminals commit crimes I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them at expressive VPN calm slash ban
now I do want to take a moment to give a
shout out to all our advertising
partners who help make this show
possible we are super grateful for our
advertising partners particularly at
this time they help keep our show going
and we certainly appreciate my listeners
going out and working with the sponsors
we're all great I wouldn't be testifying
for them otherwise I think they are
terrific we're all trying to get through
this together and they offer some great
services so if you can afford to shop
right now if you got money and if you
like any other services please continue
to patronize our advertising partners
they keep the show going they help us
bring in enough money to keep our
employees employed I know that everybody
is having a tough time right now
financially and I really appreciate both
your listenership
and the fact that you patronize our
advertising partners I know they really
appreciate it as well also worth noting
if you notice that the market is a
little bit volatile right now when I say
a little bit of I mean insane did you
see that the price of oil actually went
negative yesterday so apparently if you
drove over to the gas station they're
just handing out checks or something I
mean I guess that's how this works now
well maybe now might be a good time to
think about diversifying into something
it never loses its value I'm talking
about precious metals over 22 million
people have now lost their jobs from the
economic fallout of coronavirus even
with the stock market having had a
slight recovery nobody knows what the
long-term impact of this thing is going
to be how long it's going to take to
recovery this is gonna look more like a
u-shaped curve and like a v-shaped curve
and all probability simply because human
behavior has changed you might want to
think about that versifying into
precious metals and you know what I'm
gonna say talk to my friends over at
Birch gold to do that call Birch gold
right now convert your traditional IRA
or 401k into a precious metals IRA if
you interested in doing something like
that I'm not saying take all your money
and stuff it into gold I'm saying that
you should take some of your money and
probably put it into precious metals as
a diversification tactic before May 31st
with a qualifying purchase Birch gold
will give you a free emergency kit this
backpack is absolutely loaded with
things you can't buy right now safeguard
your savings Birch gold they'll help
safeguard your family
like they did mine there's no obligation
you have nothing to lose to take that
first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews when a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau don't wait until
the market drops more to protect your
hard-earned savings and get your free
emergency kit takes Ben to 47 47 47
diversify today sex Ben - 47 47 47 get
the process started and ask all your
questions and they get your answers from
people that I trust okay so this
pandemic is becoming more and more
political this is perfectly expected
people simply cannot avoid the
politicization of major issues and as
we'll see this politicization in my
opinion is starting from the left it is
happening in the media it is happening
from people who desire to use this
crisis as an opportunity to push their
political priors now here's the thing if
you're conservative your political
priors are not being pushed right now I
mean truly they're not being pushed
right now there are certain natural
things that are happening like
decoupling from China that's just a
natural reaction to what's going on how
could you not be couple from a country
that's been lying ad infinitum for years
and now they're lies caused a global
pandemic and a worldwide economic
meltdown right that decoupling is just a
natural consequence of the fact that
China is an authoritarian garbage state
okay so that's sort of a natural thing
that's not a political thing do you
think conservatives are super happy
about the lockdown policies I don't
think so but a lot of conservatives
we're saying okay well then you know if
we got a lockdown for the moment so that
we can get this thing under control and
not overwhelm our health care system
then let's go ahead and do that you
think that confirmed political priors
for conservatives I don't think so but
I'm seeing a lot of folks on the Left
whose political priors are being
confirmed and you can really tell this
when the president takes action that
should be pretty obvious and suddenly
it's wildly controversial so last night
President Trump tweeted out in light of
the attack from our invisible enemy and
he's talking here about coronavirus of
course as well as the need to protect
the jobs of our great American citizens
I will be signing an executive order to
temporarily suspend immigration into the
United States and this has made people
absolutely crazy how could Trump suspend
immigration into the United States first
practically speaking immigration is
suspended courts are not processing
green cards and visas right now if
you're looking for our travel visa now
would not be the time to do it
European countries have been shutting
down travel inside Europe right the
so-called Schengen zone which was an
area of free travel has basically been
shut down right now countries are
shutting their borders to each other
inside the EU Singapore is seeing
travelers come back people who have
visas come back to singing
or in spiking a second wave of
infections in Singapore right now okay
and so why would we not be suspending
immigration right now on a practical
level the executive order will see how
it's worded but it probably isn't
actually going to do very much also does
the president have a point that we don't
actually need a huge base of more labor
coming into the country right now I mean
yeah I mean we have a surplus of labor
right now it's you're not gonna have the
the the wages artificially lowered by
having more immigrants come into the
country right now because there are just
too many people out of work if 20 to 30
million people out of work
right now so you got the health issue
you've got the economic issue
you always have concerns about
immigration and the concerns about
immigration to begin with we're always
about what our immigration policy should
look like on the one side you had people
who are sort of suggesting that people
have a right to immigrate to the United
States which of course is silly and not
true on the other side you had people
who said if you want to immigrate to the
United States you have to show how you
were going to be a net benefit to the
United States and that's why Trump has
even said that migrant workers who
constitute a heavy share of labour in
places like California will continue to
be allowed into the United States even
under this executive order so the media
are covering this as though this is just
Trump confirming his political priors
that he doesn't like immigration but the
fact is just because it confirms his
political priors doesn't necessarily
mean that he is wrong in this particular
case and I find it very bizarre that the
same Democratic Party which is now
flipped on whether we should have ban
travel from China in January
remember a couple of weeks ago Joe Biden
flipped his position on this thing now
they're playing exactly the same game
with Trump right Trump says okay we're
going to shut our borders for a bit and
the Democrats like no that's bad how
could you do that sort of thing very
terrible very very terrible okay on any
sort of rational level I don't think a
lot of Americans are looking forward to
taking in millions of people who are not
properly vetted who have not been
checked for health and presumably who
are going to increase the labor base at
a time when you doubt it's one thing to
increase the labor base when you have
more openings than people willing to
fill them it is another thing to
increase the labor base at a time when
you have 30 million people out of work
according to the New York Times in
recent weeks the Trump administration
has said health concerns justified
moving swiftly to bar asylum seekers and
undocumented immigrants from entering
the country alarming immigration
advocates who have said that Trump and
his advisers were using a global
pandemic to further hardline immigration
policies well if you're an undocumented
immigrant
you know it's kind of hard to do vet
your health background now of course we
should be not allowing people to cross
the border illegally right now are you
kidding there's a good case you
shouldn't be allowed and people were
crossing the border legally and they
infected the American population to the
tune of a minimum of eight hundred seven
hundred thousand infections to date
right and those are just the infections
that we know about the actual number of
infections is probably ten times that
the president's late-night announcement
on Monday signals his most wide-ranging
attempt yet to seal the country off from
the rest of the world as though
everybody else is not doing this
everyone is doing this like look at
other countries they're sealing off
their own borders everyone ran Israel
shut down in sporters South Korea shut
down its borders countries have shut
down their borders why because you're an
idiot not to shut down your borders
right now like Florida tried to shut its
borders to New Yorkers what are we even
talking about like why is this
controversial because again political
priors matter more than actual policy
considerations and it's because
Americans are starting to see political
priors take the place of considered
policy ramifications that they are
becoming very skeptical of the left-wing
view that we have to lock down forever
and and for all time which seems to be
one of the views remin people are saying
we're gonna lock down until they're
twenty million tests available per day
okay well when pigs fly then I guess we
can get out of lockdown sure sure and
we'll get two more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that right now you really want to know
what's going on on your property I mean
you get kids running around your
property you got people who are arriving
on a daily basis and dropping off
packages it'd be good to know if they
sneezed on the package right before they
dropped it at your door
well this is why ring.com comes in super
handy especially because some people
like Bill DeBlasio are letting criminals
out of prison like crime rates are gonna
go up ring gives you protection at every
corner helps you create custom
affordable security for your home ring
the text motion when people come onto
your property rings video doorbells let
you answer the door
check in on your home anytime from
anywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivery or a surprise
visitor you'll get an alert and be able
to see hear and speak to them all from
your phone yet peace of mind knowing
that your loved ones are safe the
all-new ring video doorbell three it's
upgraded with additional security
features and works on any home you can
see and speak with visitors with HD
video and 2-way talk and get
notifications when your doorbell detects
movement you can adjust what areas you
have motion alerts for see you only
receive alerts that you actually care
about and they've got dual band Wi-Fi
bringing you more flexible and reliable
connections there
constantly upgrading the nature of these
devices and they are excellent I mean
they really do help keep your property
safe
I am very safety concerned as you know
there is safety conscious and I've been
using ring on my own property for years
you should to get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit when you go to ring
calm slash pen the welcome kit includes
that ring up video doorbell 3 and chime
Pro it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today just
go to ring.com slash been again that is
ring.com slash been alrighty so first
there's this controversy over the over
the immigration shutdown workers who
have for years received visas to perform
specialized jobs in the united states
would be tonight permission to arrive
the some workers and industries deemed
critical will be exempted from the band
apparently that will include health care
workers so people who are tweeting out
stats as to how many immigrants are in
the health care system those people will
still be allowed to come in and work the
number of visas issued to formers abroad
looking to immigrate to the United
States has already declined by about 25
percent in this fiscal year it's set to
decline it still further this should not
be all that controversial nonetheless it
is massively controversial the New York
Times obviously is is ripping this thing
up and down suggesting that it is all
basically a lie under an executive order
the Trump administration would no longer
approve applications from foreigners to
live and work in the US for an
undetermined period of time effectively
shutting down the legal immigration
system in the same way the president has
long advocated closing the borders to
illegal immigration so and again dude do
I think that this is a violation of law
no he's got pretty broad authority in
this area
the president has pretty significant
authority when it comes to borders and
immigration beyond that now is a good
time to shut the borders I mean that's
just the reality of the situation
meanwhile speaking of people who are
confirming their political priors
so yesterday oil future is completely
dumped I mean down to negative 37
dollars and 36 and 63 cents people were
paying people to take barrels of oil off
their hands why because there literally
is no storage facility the fact is that
right now what we are watching is a
collapse in demand and there's one of
the problems is when you talk about the
recovery one of the things that you have
to look at is how much has the
underlying demand curve actually changed
because people's behavior has changed so
nobody's driving right now the oil
industry isn't tanking for financial
reasons or systemic reasons it is
tanking because no one is driving and
because businesses are not operating and
that means that nobody has any use for
oil so there's a glut of
on the market and oil has an expiration
date and it needs to be refined and it's
more expensive right now to refine it
than it would be to just dump it at this
point and do nothing with it and so the
futures contracts which are gonna take
hold in May on May 1st basically the oil
companies are betting that there will be
no buyers for the oil and there will be
a complete glut of oil so this is
obviously not great for the oil industry
because if they can't make profit then
they're going to start shutting down the
pumping and what you're going to see is
that these oil companies are not
supremely flexible that as the economy
ramps back up they're going to start
pumping again but slower American
fracking is actually a lot more flexible
and is gonna fill some of that gap which
is not a bad thing for American fracking
but when I say confirming political
priors let me show you a perfect example
so the oil prices dump in historic
fashion historic fashion right according
to the New York Times prices went
negative meaning that anyone trying to
sell a barrel would have to pay a buyer
30 bucks in part because of the way all
is traded futures contracts that require
buyers to take possession of oil in May
are expiring on Tuesday nobody wants the
oil because there's no place to store it
so aoc immediately tweets out a couple
of absolutely asinine things because she
is a okay not gonna sugarcoat this
representative Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
has the IQ of a kumquat maybe a loquat
on the upper end okay she really just
she she's just an idiot okay so she
tweets out you absolutely love to see it
this along with record low interest
rates means it's the right time for a
worker LED mass investment in green
infrastructure to save our planet
Koff okay so I'm not sure why she is why
she's coughing I mean I hope that all is
well with AO sees health but first of
all to celebrate you absolutely love to
see the collapse of the oil industry
that supports tens of thousands of
American jobs really that's good so she
deleted that one but then she put up a
new tweet and her new tweet is just as
stupid she tweets now is the time to
create millions of good jobs building
out the infrastructure and clean energy
necessary to save our planet for future
generations
for our economy our planet in our future
we need a green new deal I don't think
she understands how prices work she's
read out this snapshot is being
acknowledged as a turning point in the
climate movement fossil fuels are in
long-term structural decline this along
with low interest rates means it's the
right time to create millions of jobs
transition to
and clean-energy a key opportunity what
in the actual f is she talking about
oil they're paying you to take oil and
she's like this is a great time to
invest in windmills great time to invest
in windmills we should drop down her
head as a small child I can't think of
any other explanation
bu needs to get she should get a read
like I'm gonna I'm gonna advocate for a
OC to get her college tuition waived
from bu because she did not get her
money's worth I choose an econ double
major at bu and somehow she graduated
with a degree this does not speak well
of Boston University so if she is
looking for a legal advocate for her
free tuition at BU she didn't get
anything for her money hey there's no
consideration in that particular
contract when the price of oil is zero
that is a horrible time to invest in
windmills and green energy what the f
are you talking about
this is sort of like saying you know did
you see there's a glut of chocolate on
the market the price of chocolate is
zero like it's literally zero you could
walk into the supermarket right now and
just pick up they'll pay you to take
bags of chocolate back to your house
have you ever thought of a better time
to buy kale what what are you what like
the whole point is now's a great time to
fill up your car right now is a horrible
time to invest in expensive alternative
energies when the prep like does she not
understand the purpose of a carbon tax
right the purpose of a carbon tax is to
artificially raise the price of oil to
artificially raise the price of filling
your car so that it creates an economic
incentive for you to instead invest in
more expensive alternative energies
which thanks to the raised price of oil
would now be lower in cost than the oil
but if the prices of oil drop no one in
the like are you buying an
energy-efficient vehicle for more money
when the cost of oil is zero she's a
full scale idiot but again this is
confirmation bias at work right she's
just confirming her priors
she's just confirming her priors and
when you see people confirming their
priors their priors
it does make you suspicious it does make
you suspicious that people are not being
honest about broad-scale public policy
see right now if you want people to take
life-altering measures like staying at
home right like keeping their kids at
home no summer camps no movies no
restaurants no eating out you want
people to shelter in place you're gonna
need a high level of trust and that
is gonna have to be based on the idea
that you are not doing this for an
ulterior motive
all right think about your daily life
there are so many things where you rely
on people not having an ulterior motive
right somebody says to you that you
bring in a car and your car is broken
and bring it to an auto body shop and
they say okay well we need to replace
the transmission and then you find out
that they are being subsidized by the
transmission company and for every
transmission they sell they're getting a
200 kickback well that's gonna change
your math on whether you actually need
to replace the transmission isn't it
now you're gonna think to yourself oh
this person has an ulterior motive maybe
they're not being honest with me
in order for there to be any level of
trust in the most broad ranging and deep
measures in American history there is
going to mean in terms of civilian
populations there's gonna have to be a
high level of trust that Trust is being
undermined each and every day by
partisan actors who obviously are
attempting to confirm their own priors
rather than looking at the actual events
on the ground they're wooden get to more
of this in just one second plus there's
there is some good news right there is
some good news and that is that there is
some again more information more and
more information coming out that this
thing is not nearly as deadly as we had
previously supposed that doesn't mean
that it is that it is not deadly it does
not mean that it is not easily
transmitted but study after study after
study is now showing that the actual
infection fatality rate meaning the
number of people who are infected right
on the denominator the number of people
who are dead in the numerator right that
that that percentage is actually a lot
lower than we'd been led to believe when
you get to that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that now is a
horrible time to go to the post office
now you may love the post office maybe
it's a great place to be now it's not a
great time to schlep packages into a
place where there are lots of people in
a closed building right this is not a
good idea
instead what you want to be doing is
shipping those packages from home and
doing it safely and easily this is why
you need stamps.com anything you can do
at the post office you can do at stamps
con we've been using stamps calm here at
the Daily wire since 2017 we have saved
innumerable gobs of money and can print
postage on demand skip the lines and
crowds at the post office plus you can
actually save some money with discounts
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer so you can use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it once that mail is ready
just leave it for the mail carrier his
schedule free package pickup you drop
into mail box no human contact required
which is exactly what you're looking for
right now you get five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 40% off US
Postal Service shipping rates now in
addition to offering discounts at US
postal rates stamps com also is offering
UPS services with discounts up to 62
percent plus with stamps com you won't
even have to pay ups at residential
surcharges stamps calm it's a no-brainer
especially now it saves you time it
saves you money and it keeps you safe in
these crazy times right now
my listeners can get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and the digital scale no
long-term commitment go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro talk about
a service you can use right now this is
it stamps com click on that Mike at the
top of the homepage and type in Shapiro
so up another piece of good news I've
been telling you about these studies and
this is like just the latest right study
after study after study showing that the
actual number of people who are infected
in society is far higher than the number
of people who are dying and that the
case fatality rate the infection
fatality rate is the total number of
infected case fatality rate is the
number of confirmed cases so I've been
using case fatality rate for weeks
really should've been saying infection
fatality rate to be a little more exact
okay the infection fatality rate is a
lot lower than people have been saying
according to hot air John Sexton writing
earlier this month researchers from the
University of Southern California Keck
School of Medicine set up drive-through
testing sites in six locations around LA
County the researchers used a
proprietary database they say is
representative of the entire county and
gave people an antibody test what they
found is that far more people in LA
County have had the virus than are aware
of it the research is unfinished it
hasn't yet been peer reviewed but LA
County public health officials published
the early results they showed that
around four percent of people in LA
County already had the virus adjusting
the estimate for statistical margin of
error that means anywhere from two point
eight percent to five point six percent
of the county's adult population has
antibodies to the virus that translates
to anywhere from two hundred twenty one
thousand to four hundred and forty two
thousand adults in LA County alone who
have had the infection the number of
kovat related deaths in the county has
now surpassed six hundred the press
release doesn't do the math what that
actually means is that the death rate
currently for coronavirus with the
current death toll of 617 if you took
four point one percent right in that mid
range you're looking at a death rate of
something like point two percent which
is about twice the rate of the flu
so the good news is that a lot of people
may have had this with few if any
symptoms the bad news is that the LA
County case rate is still only 5% so we
are not close to herd immunity but it is
also true that there has not really herd
immunity to the flu there's not hurting
me under the flip button the the there
have been several studies at this point
there's one from Wuhan one from the
Netherlands I talked about it one from
Massachusetts one from King County
Washington one from the the hospital in
New York and and all of them are showing
that the actual case fatality rate is a
lot lower than has been shown right that
it is anywhere from point two percent to
point six percent on the upper end
probably okay that is good news I mean
that means this thing is a lot less
deadly than previously supposed and
again if you are young and you are
healthy the chances that you're going to
die from this thing are exceedingly low
which is why I've been suggesting that
testing is really designed to do one
thing and one thing only prevent hot
spots from flaring up that's all testing
can do ok testing isn't gonna prevent
you from getting this thing testing
isn't going to prevent you it may delay
you getting this thing over time it may
prevent a widespread pandemic outbreak
that overwhelms the healthcare system
but that's how we should be judging
public policy right now one of the
things that I hate more than anything
this is why I think the media coverage
also is confirming political priors a
lot of the media coverage right now is
just not accurate a lot of the media
coverage when it comes to flattening the
curve suggested that the number of
people who are going to be infected was
going to be lowered overall by the
flattening of the curve that's not the
idea of flattening the curve the adults
the goal of flattening the curve was to
prevent overload of the healthcare
system but the area under the curve is
still the same if the curve looks like
this and I'm making a very high wave in
the air and then very low after or it
looks like this a flatter wave but the
maintenance level is higher at the end
okay the area under the curve is still
the same so you're still gonna get
infected it just maybe four months from
now as opposed to right now so that you
don't overwhelm the the healthcare
system the reason this matters is
because when you're talking about
testing you have to be accurate about
what exactly you are attempting to do
and there's been this idea out there I
spoke to dr. Marty Meharry from Johns
Hopkins University yesterday on the show
right he's advised both Trump and Obama
okay so he is not partisan and dr.
Meharry basically confirmed what I was
saying which is that testing is not
designed to prevent everyone from
getting this thing it's designed to
prevent them from being a major spike in
an area because the testing
city itself is not sufficient to stop
one person from infecting a bunch of
other people around them in the
immediate basis is just enough to help
contain it
so that you can contact trace for some
people so that's what the testing is
designed to do if we're accurate about
that then we can be more accurate about
what testing is actually designed to do
how much testing is necessary and we can
throw out these estimates that suggest
that we're gonna have to have 20 million
tests a day in order so that people can
go back to work there's just a bunch of
crap it's not real it's not true and
there's a reason that even doctor foul
has been suggesting it's more like
300,000 tests a day dr. Gottlieb has
been suggesting that Scott Gottlieb from
former FDA Commissioner it is not 20
million tests a day and this is why
you're starting to see states that are
reopening businesses because these
states are basically saying all we can
do at this point is do what we can do
which means let responsible citizens be
responsible and that's not a bad thing
right you just have to make sure that
the policies that you are taking are
indeed responsible that they balance the
risk and the reward of reopening and
that you have enough systems in place so
that you can hotspot and contact race
now the hot spot and contact tracing
again are not designed to prevent
infection overall over the long haul
that's how that's not they do what they
are designed to do is prevent the
overwhelming of the healthcare system so
when you look at places that are opening
up more it is a foolish thing a very
foolish thing that the media are doing
by focusing in on the near-term effect
of removal of lockdowns you saw this in
their coverage of Sweden I've been
saying this for weeks
Sweden took a different strategy their
strategy was more people will be
infected in the near term and more
people will die in the near term than
they will in the Netherlands or than
they will in in Denmark right that was
their policy and their policy was the
area under the curve will be the same
but we have not shut down our economy
and people are going to continue to go
out they're gonna be able to live their
lives to a certain extent our economy
will not take the same sort of hit as
other economies will take but that was
Sweden's policy and people like oh look
at that they have more deaths and more
infections than Netherlands yeah because
in other ones everybody staying home
right because in if you lock down of
course there are lower deaths and lower
infections in the near term but that's
not how you gauge a policy as I said
yesterday the person at the gym who's
working who's finally getting in shape
and working off the weight and vomiting
in the corner looks like a sucker to the
guy sitting on the couch but over the
course of the next year when that guy
gets in fit gets in shape and the and
guy on the couch is struggling for
breath that didn't look like a sucker's
play did it
okay well Sweden is basically saying we
are trying to do the responsible thing
well not destroying our economy and
people are like well in the near term
there are more yes engineers from there
more infections guess what when we all
go back to work right when we all go
back to our offices when kids go back to
school there will be more infections and
there will be more deaths and that does
not mean that the counter-narrative or
that the counterfactual would have been
better that we stay in our houses for a
long period of time because eventually
we're all gonna come out unless somebody
comes up with a miracle vaccine right
all we are doing is buying time and
preventing the healthcare system from
being overwhelmed those are the only
things we can do there are no drugs that
cure this thing there is no vaccine so
with those things in place all we're
gonna really be able to do is minimize
the number of people who are elderly and
who have pre-existing conditions who are
out there in public and that's gonna
rely on personal responsibility and yes
regulations about visiting nursing homes
and such and we are going to put in
place some testing and contact tracing
such that there aren't these massive
spikes in areas that overwhelm the
healthcare system but like can we please
be accurate about this when people are
being inaccurate it makes me think that
maybe they have that ulterior motive
again because I think there are a lot of
ulterior motives running around I'll get
to that in just one second okay so this
has become a point of contention because
you can see how people are being stupid
about this in the media you can see how
they're covering Florida how they're
covering Georgia so Florida beaches in
Jacksonville for example in Jacksonville
they reopen their beaches that doesn't
mean that they were like okay everybody
go out and party it's Spring Break time
and do it no what they said is social
distance walk six feet away from other
people wear a mask and then if you want
to go walk along the beach go walk along
the beach and the meeting went nuts look
at these pictures from Jacksonville
where people are standing seven feet
apart from each other this is terrible
first of all the amount of actual
infection in outdoor areas where people
are socially distancing is nil okay it
is very very low when you're seeing
stories from places where there's a mass
outbreak outdoors it's because people
were right on top of each other it's
because it was Cancun spring break
actual real world right that that's like
MTV shows right people people making out
on the beach and slipping each other
right that that's that is close personal
contact but that's not what's happening
in Jacksonville so dr. deborah birx
yesterday who's been his kasha sound
this is anybody in the White House and
she says Florida beaches reopening
that's that's called being responsible
because they don't
have a lot of cases out there and people
are socially distancing Florida
Department of Health website is
extraordinary and this is what every
department of health should have because
when you go to that website you can see
that most of the cases are in southern
Florida in the Miami Fort Lauderdale
Broward County area and if you look in
Jacksonville they had less than 20 cases
per day
and less than 800 in four weeks and so
these are the kinds when you inform the
public and give them the information
that they need then they can make
decisions along with the local
government and governor's what you mean
treating American citizens is are
they're responsible actors in Republic
Wow I know it just crazy crazy stuff how
do our people do this sort of stuff okay
so these states that are also coming in
for all sorts of criticism include South
Carolina and Georgia so according to the
New York Times South Carolina allowed
retail shops ranging from department
stores to flea markets to reopen on
Monday afternoon shortly after its
governor Henry McMaster signed an
executive order reversing some of the
closings he ordered earlier this month
on Friday residents of Georgia will be
allowed to return to the gym and get
haircuts pedicures mess massages and
tattoos according to Governor Brian Kemp
next Monday they can dine in restaurants
and go to the movies Tennessee stay at
home order will expire April 30th
allowing most businesses there to reopen
on May 1st according to Governor Bill
Lee that moves by three Republican
governors of southern states to let some
businesses reopen came as the outbreak
continued to spread in parts of the
nation and as some other governors and
public health experts have warned in
recent days that testing remained
inadequate to quickly identify and
contain new outbreaks Massachusetts has
been particularly hard-hit recently at
the White House briefing on Monday
evening dr. deborah birx coronavirus
response coordinator noted we stole the
significant number of cases in the
Boston area and across Massachusetts and
Chicago President Trump
outlined non-biting guy non-binding
guidelines last week for states to ease
the restrictions South Carolina is
moving to let its retail stores reopen
Monday at 5:00 p.m. but they have to
adhere to social distancing requirements
they have to operate at 20% occupancy
you are at five customers per 1,000
square feet whichever is less okay which
by the way is the same policy that they
are undertaking in Germany opening shops
and then telling people that the
occupancy is now one one fifth one
quarter of what it used to be that's
what they have been doing in Europe okay
so South Carolina's policy is no
different from what Europe is doing it
also said businesses should not allow
customers to
within six feet of one another the state
plans to reopen public beach access
points piers docks and wharves at noon
on Tuesday which again make sense just
stay away from each other this is called
the responsible citizens being
responsible in Georgia Kemp said at a
news conference the state would allow
the reopening of gyms of bowling alleys
and salons on Friday he said his
decisions would be the operational
standard in all jurisdictions
he says local action cannot be taken
that is more or less restrictive he said
that theaters private social clubs and
dining restaurants would be allowed to
open April 27 bars nightclubs live
performance venues would remain closed
and you are seeing some businesses
reopen as soon as next Monday in
Tennessee now the the Georgia order is
broader than the South Carolina order
and this is the one that has come under
the most scrutiny on a personal level I
think that the riskiest sensors here are
probably places like gyms bowling alleys
seem pretty risky I mean you're
literally sticking your hands on objects
that other people are sticking their
hands on so the transmission of this
thing on objects is is pretty high but
barbers are sort of different thing they
are there if everybody is wearing a mask
and a barber is working on you that's
less risky Hair Designers nail care
artists all of those areas seem less
dangerous again people are acting as
though Kemp said that you should just go
out and party it up this is not right
all of these areas are allowed to reopen
only with specific social distancing
guidelines and sanitation mandates
including enhanced workplace sanitation
the minimum basic operations you have to
do this if you want to reopen in Georgia
screening workers for fever and
respiratory illness so they're doing
fever checks enhancing workplace
sanitation wearing masks and gloves
separating workplaces by 6 feet
teleworking if possible and staggered
shift so again the media are covering
this thing as though he's basically
saying go out willy-nilly enjoy yourself
that is not correct
this is not correct so and if you are
still afraid then you don't have to go
out and do this it will be interesting
to see what happens in Georgia it'll be
interesting to see if the health care
system is overwhelmed so the only way
that you are going to be able to judge
whether Georgia is doing the right thing
or the wrong thing is effort I'm too
late now it's like Sweden right what is
their health care system overwhelm if
their health care system was not
overwhelmed well then this is just
what's called living in public and also
people should use their own best
judgment okay if you are elderly you
should stay indoors if you are a and
away from other people if
have pre-existing conditions you should
not go out and party it up everybody
should be acting responsibly with masks
and social distancing from the way the
media are covering this thing is though
Kemp did something that is completely
evil I again don't see that at this
point is it when worn off - you're
responsible if there is a spike and it
is not detected by testing and contact
tracing because that's the only thing
that can be prevented I'm only going to
judge the activity of governor's by this
stuff they can prevent okay well and and
the stuff they can and when I'm on I
mean the stuff they can prevent there
gonna be people to say well you can
prevent everything by keeping everybody
home forever that's not a realistic
solution okay California will release at
some point New York will release at some
point and they will be doing exactly the
same sorts of stuff that Kemp is doing
they'll just do it three weeks from now
or a month from now or six weeks from
now and the only way you're gonna be
able to tell whether temp was right or
wrong is after a year what were the
death rates in in Georgia adjusting for
population size adjusting for
demographics adjusting for pre-existing
health conditions versus California
people are gonna try and judge this
thing in real time people are going to
try and judge this thing as though
there's a spike in cases in Georgia
because people are out and about again
yes because people are out and about and
that is expected I'm assuming that
Georgia knows this that the rates are
not going to be the same as they are if
you walk everybody in their homes
obviously okay in a second we're gonna
get to why this is becoming so political
and it is becoming really political
because politics always intrude when it
comes to massive public policy decisions
like all of this we'll get it we'll get
to all of that in a moment because as
you will see you know when it comes to
pushing priors as I keep saying we are
now seeing a serious movement on the
left to suggest that anybody who wants
to reopen in measured smart fashion that
anybody who actually wants to reopen
based on the evidence once lives to be
lost which is that that's the first
resort of people who are full of crap if
you ever hear somebody say this
political conversation I can't even have
this conversation you just want people
to die that's all you just want people
that yeah go after yourself like
seriously that's not a conversation
that's just you insulting me as a bad
person which means you don't wanna have
a conversation it means that you're an
irresponsible political adversary okay
and then says that's that that is the
tactic the tactic is you want people to
die if you disagree with people on the
Left who want full-scale lockdown
presumably for a very very long time and
then the actual agenda item is
remaking of American society and we're
starting to see that rolled out in
serious fashion right that the crisis is
an opportunity whether it's a OSE
suggesting that an oil drop is an
opportunity to invest in green energy
which of course makes as much sense as a
screen door in a submarine or an ejector
seat on a helicopter or whether you are
a person who is suggesting that we need
to completely remake America's economic
system because there is a pandemic and
because this has exposed all the evils
of American society these are the
ulterior motives it's why people are
saying I don't want you in control
because I think that you actually have
conflicting motives here not that you
want the economy to die not that you're
a bad person but you think that it's a
double win I keep people at home longer
and fewer people die in the near term
and also this gives me an opportunity to
broaden the size and scope of government
well what if I want the economy to
recover because I think that's actually
a priority and a serious thing and
people need to have jobs in the private
sector yeah we'll get to more of this in
just one second first being locked
inside right now it requires a double
the excitement what could be more
exciting than wait for it look at this
here's one left is tears tumblr
wait for it wait for it wait for a
second left is tears tumblr they're
propagating this tumblr begat bad tumblr
what is this sorcery well right now when
you become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member you get a second
leftist ears tumblr I know unbelievable
I'm not lying to you I am not kidding
existing members its natural to feel a
little jealous don't worry we have a
special offer coming up just for the
people who already members daily where
our members get many amazing benefits
including of course these magnificent
you're replaceable singular you also get
an ad-free website experience access to
all of our live broadcast and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight op-eds
from me daily where members also get to
ask us questions during backstage you
also get to participate in all access
live that is our brand-new interactive
program and featuring one of us daily
wire hosts as we hang out with you each
night 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific I did one last then I showed off
the guns that's right you miss the gun
show if you haven't already download the
daily wire app so you can get all of our
great content on the go again become an
insider plus all-access member double
your tears with two leftist chairs
tumblers or the tears of your enemies go
to daily wear calm slash subscribe to
get started and get 10% off with coupon
code Shapiro that is daily wear calm /
subscribe coupon code Shapiro get the
rarest of all beverage vessels times two
don't a little bit of Spanish lingo for
either also as a reminder you can join
us tomorrow for a special socially
distanced edition of daily wire
backstage I've been able to avoid
Michael moles during this pandemic that
ends tomorrow night and I am NOT looking
forward to it that will be tomorrow
Wednesday the 21st 4:00 p.m. Pacific
time you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you
so politics never stops of course and
the politics of the of the current
negotiations over another bailout
package those politics have not ceased
either Democrats keep insisting on
loading up this bill with more and more
and more stuff including now they want
bailouts for states and localities now
if a state or locality has incurred cost
at the behest of the federal government
it makes sense that the federal
government should backfill that but if
states and localities are just looking
for a bailout for the fact that they've
run their states like garbage for years
this seems like a stupid policy and I
don't know why California's
mismanagement should be the fault of
Texas I don't know why New York state
deficit should be the fault of Texas
right now according to the according to
the Washington Post I believe a
Republican and Democrat in the Senate
are proposing a five hundred billion
dollar fund for state and local
governments as part of the next
comprehensive rescue package from
Congress apparently they want a hundred
and fifty billion dollars from municipal
municipalities virus expenses but the
the one that was won in March it
provided for virus expenses but it
didn't address budget shortfalls a
budget shortfalls like I'm sorry you're
gonna have to explain to me why Texas
should have to assume the cost of money
that California has already spent like
California's been fiscally irresponsible
for years and now they're going to go to
the federal government ask for a bailout
that that is political that is just as
political as people asking for bailouts
of companies that don't deserve a
bailout right they weren't damaged by
this just ran their companies badly
meanwhile speaking meanwhile speaking of
again the partisan politics here the New
York Times is suggesting this thing
became political because of the
right-wing right this is the line the
line is that the that the right wing has
made this political Jeremy Peters
reporting for the New York Times has a
piece called how abortion guns and
church closings made coronavirus a
culture war he says this is what it
looks like when a pandemic collides with
the culture wars in America the mayor of
Louisville Kentucky warned churches that
holding services on Easter Sunday would
defy the city's social distancing
guidelines Mitch McConnell answered but
the stern letter arguing religious
people should not be singled out for
disfavored treatment the Democratic
governor in Michigan extended bans on
certain outdoor activities to include
using motor boats conservatives called
her an authoritarian and caricatured
removes a slap at people who enjoy the
outdoors even though firearms stores
remain free to do business in most of
the country the NRA
has a stark message for gun owners they
want your guns and they want them all
this is what Charlie Daniels said in a
promotional video the new patchwork of
state and local policies designed to
flatten the spread of coronavirus is
inflaming old passions over some of the
most contentious issues in politics well
maybe it's inflaming passions because
the policies have been patchwork
inconsistent and having nothing to do
with public health Kristine Whitmer in
Gretchen Whitmer rather in in Michigan
is telling people they cannot take a
motor boat out on the lake but they can
take a boat that does not have a motor
out on the lake by the way but you can
get an abortion
so no buying seeds at the local Target
but definitely make sure you can have an
abortion an essential service to have an
abortion is that maybe her not actually
saying something about public health but
saying something about politics when you
have people suggesting that churches
should be singled out as places for
public gathering not just general
policies saying don't get together in
big groups and that includes everything
from churches to social groups to movie
theaters right that's a general policy
and by the way I'm a religious person
who goes to synagogue regularly and I
was advocating for the shut down of
synagogues before like anybody else
right I specifically avoided poram
parties in my neighborhood because of
all of this and I've been pretty strong
on this there is a difference between
that and singling out religious
institutions could it be that maybe the
reaction has been driven by the petty
authoritarianism of people who seemed to
be reveling in their newfound Authority
could it be that a lot of people in the
media have been pumping up a political
vision of this in which President Trump
is to blame for every ill but every
governor who takes an authoritarian
action is somehow a hero could it be the
one the media prop up Andrew Cuomo as
somehow being America's governor at a
time when he completely blew it in New
York by the way according to the New
York Times he blew it in New York and he
should have shut down a week and a half
earlier two weeks earlier and then they
propped him up as like a hero because he
kept yelling about how the federal
government needed sended ventilators and
his rich Lowry has written a National
Review the federal government did send
ventilators and New York did not need
40,000 ventilators and the federal
government was trying to be flexible so
other states would also have access to
ventilators and when all of that
happened the media portrayed it as
though Trump was evil and Cuomo was good
is it possible this thing was political
and then the right is responding to the
politicization and saying well it seems
to me that I can't trust you to be
honest about this sort of stuff is it
possible the
got political when you have a poll out
today that shows that 60% of Democrats
say that Trump is more to blame for the
current crisis than China is according
to a Rasmussen poll they were 42% of
u.s. voters agreed with Senator Chris
Murphy recent statement the reason we're
in the crisis is not because of anything
China did not because of the w-h-o it's
because of what President Trump did 60%
of Democrats agree with Murphy that
Trump is more to blame than China in the
whu-oh is it possible that we didn't
start the politicization here on the
right is that possible is it possible
then when we look at people on the Left
who are eager and just jumping champing
at the bit to remake the entire American
system to tear down the private health
care system to tear down free markets to
suggest massive redistribution and
slavery reparations and all sorts of
leftist goodies they wanted five minutes
ago but now they want on the back of a
pandemic is it possible that we're
saying to you guys well maybe you have
an ulterior motive here I'm seeing piece
after piece released suggesting that
America sucks right this is that this is
the new talking point is that America
sucks and therefore we need vast change
again this is this is what is driving a
lot of the resistance like okay well if
my choice is that I have to look at
America being turned upside down and
inside out and the and the nature of
America changed deeply because of the
pandemic if I wait three more weeks or
six more weeks to go back to work so
that the testing is slightly better or I
can go back to work now and urge my
governor to go back to work now because
the testing is already sufficient or I
think the testing will be ramped up in
the next two weeks and I want to get
back to work and I don't want to rely on
government benefits and I don't want to
spend the next 60 days entrenching
government largesse then I'm evil right
if they if that's the logic of the left
then I think this is a little bit
political and the media are so dishonest
in all of this there there's honest
good-faith disagreement about what is
the actual tipping point when you can
actually go back to work right that's it
that's an actual good faith argument
that can be had based on data we have
the argument every day here right I've
had conversations with nearly every
health expert at the top of government
about this and there's no clear-cut
answer it is a sliding scale
there's no binary decision where you
flick on and it's safe and you flick off
and it's not safe that's not the way any
of this works these are hard decisions
but the way the media are portraying
this is that it's not a hard
at all the easy decision is stay at home
and also by the way we're gonna change
everything you love about America and
it's never gonna come back right we're
gonna get to this in just one second so
let's take for example Don Lemon right
so Don Lemon over at CNN objective
journalist Don Lemon very journalism II
lots and lots of journalism right he
says that the only people who want to
reopen they only want to reopen because
they want a haircut this is the most
dismissive garbage bullcrap I've heard
in a long time the reason that people
want to go back to work and have a job
is because they want a haircut no Don
I'm pretty sure it's because there are
people who are now going to food banks
because they don't have food in their
fridge Don Lemon is over at the CNN
studios with a job and with a salary and
Chris Cuomo is able to work from home
even with coronavirus how about all the
people who don't have jobs today and who
have had their dreams stripped away as
their small business has been tanked by
the economy and tank by the the force of
the federal and state governments Tom
lemon sneering at people who want to go
back to work maybe I think if you
mischaracterize your opposition this
badly then maybe I don't trust you when
it comes to broad scale public policy
here's some women being jerk you're
slapping the faces the people who are
the health care workers who put their
lives on the line every day because you
want a haircut you want to go play golf
you're concerned about of course you're
concerned about your business tell the
president that and you're out there with
with with guns with with weapons
strapped to your chest saying oh you
want to get your you're fighting against
the people who are telling you to stay
at home trying to save your lives you're
upset with those people in the meantime
they're people who are keeping your
cities going keeping your loved ones
alive and you want to get a haircut how
do you think you are okay the people who
are protesting by and large are not
people who just want a haircut like the
minimization of the concerns on the
other side of this coin are insane
that's insane okay this is great
depression levels of a kind of economic
economic collapse and you say oh well
you know you just broma what the hell is
he talking about it's it's just it's
wild it's wild and when you see again
members of the of the media who are who
are just they cannot contain themselves
at the amount of change they want to
perform on the American system on the
back of this thing it makes people
suspicious
it makes people deeply suspicious and
there's an article two separate
articles in the newer times today one
called the ideas that won't survive the
coronavirus by yet fanon you when Kovac
19 is killing off the myth we are the
greatest country on Earth oh here we go
so now it's all about how America sucks
shocker
shocker if anything good emerges out of
this period says this columnist it might
be an awakening to the pre-existing
conditions of our body politic we are
not as healthy as we thought we were the
biological virus afflicting individuals
is a social virus it's symptoms
inequality callousness selfishness
a profit motive that undervalues human
life in over values commodities or for
too long masked by the hearty good cheer
of American exceptionalism the ruddiness
of someone a few steps away from a heart
attack profit motive oh you mean you
know the profit motive that's actually
getting people to produce the masks and
the ventilators and all of medical
equipment and the PPE s
and then it's keeping our hospitals open
in flexible fashion in a way Italy was
not able to and the NHS in Britain was
not able to the the eagerness that is
desire to completely remake the American
economy on the back of a pandemic yeah
it makes me suspicious that you are fine
with staying at home because yes you get
to claim that you are saving more lives
in the near term and also you get to
then perform all the changes you've
always wanted to perform this comment
says even if America as we know it
survives the coronavirus it can hardly
emerge unscathed if the illusion of
invincibility is shredded for any
patient who survives in your fatal
experience what might die after Kovan
nineteen is a myth we are the best
country on Earth a belief common even
among the poor the marginal the
precariat who must believe in their own
Americanist if in nothing else no
america is bad very very bad very bad
and that america has a history of
settler colonization and capitalism that
ruth will ruthlessly exploited natural
resources and people typically the poor
the migratory the black in the brown
that history manifests itself today in
our impulse to hoard knowing we live in
an economy of self-reliance and scarcity
and our dependence on the cheap labor of
women and racial minorities okay and and
then you're telling me to stay home the
general responsive americans so this is
going to be people like you were telling
me to stay home go take a hike son like
no that is not that is not something I'm
willing to do take a hike and truly just
take a hike buddy is it's just
unbelievable assembly and this is not
the only article like this right that
Charlie Juarez le the opinion writer at
large for the New York Times has a piece
today called
protesting for the freedom to catch the
coronavirus the reopen America protests
are the logical conclusion of a twisted
Liberty movement twisted you see he says
that a string of small reopen America
protests across the country this week
maskless citizens proudly flowered
social distancing guidelines while
openly carrying semi-automatic rifles
and waving American flags and signs with
ironic swastikas okay I love how he's
not picking he's not going after the
majority of people there who were
socially distancing and just holding
signs like I want to get back to work he
finds the craziest people in the crowd
which is the easiest game in American
politics but the idea is that this is
just like the Tea Party because the Tea
Party was a bunch of nuts who wanted
smaller government and so are these
people they're nuts
now what we need right now is bigger
government and anybody who rejects this
doesn't care about human life they don't
care about human life it's it's really
quite amazing it really is quite amazing
you you you want to know why people are
not paying attention to your
recommendations on policy because we
don't believe you that you are honest
about what you think it will take to
stop the pandemic
and what it will take to get back
working again we think that you want to
change the American economy and that
you're more than happy to sit around
until that happens are a temperate thing
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like today there is a
new series on on Hulu VFX called Deb's
it's great it's it's made by Alex
Griswold I believe is named is who is
the guy behind the guy behind ex machina
garland thank you Alex garland and and
Alex Griswold works here anyway
Alex Garland and and dev's is basically
the premise is that they've designed a
machine that is capable of identifying
down to the most microscopic portions of
any physical object everything about
that object which means that you can
then extrapolate out from that thing all
of passed in all the future so the basic
metaphor that's used in the series is
that if you push a pencil and it rolls
across the desk and you could measure
the pencil like really measure the
movement of the pencil you could see how
much force is applied on it you could
fill in how hard it was pushed who
pushed it what that person's body mass
was you could actually extrapolate the
past and the future how fast that's
gonna roll and so the whole series about
determinism in free well I think it's
fascinating I kind of love this series
they hear a little bit the preview
know what happened to him if you came
for answers ask me what you don't know
what is steps this is the only principle
you need to understand nothing ever
happens without a reason
everything was determined by something
prior they're fanatics we need the
police you want to take them down it's
impossible it's it's really quite good
nick offerman turns in a very very good
performance by allison peel is super
creepy it's it's it's a great series and
more of this on TV seriously like this
is really highly intelligence television
I kinda really I kind of love it it's
pretty spectacular so go check that out
okay time for some things that I hate so
as I say that there's been a complete
push on the left for this idea that we
need to completely remake the American
system because this is pre it's exposing
all of the evils of American society
which is amazing because basically we
now have an unfalsifiable thesis from
the left if things are going really well
that's a mask for all the bad things
happening in American society if things
are going really poorly then that is
exposing all of the bad things that are
happening in American society so no
matter how you slice it bad things are
happening and it requires complete
remaking of the system Elizabeth Warren
senator was pushing this nonsense she
she was suggesting that the disparities
in health outcomes for black and white
women it has to be because health care
professionals are racist or something
and really that this is what she is
pushing she's pushing the disparities in
black maternity mortality statistics
right which has been pushed by everybody
from Stacey Abrams to the New York Times
neglecting to mention the fact by the
way if there are racial disparities and
outcomes in Europe as well which doesn't
have the same history as the United
States obviously and also neglects to
mention that there are pre-existing
conditions that run concomitant to to
race it's not caused by race but they
are but there there is crossover that
largely explained black maternal
mortality rates being higher namely
malnutrition in the womb obesity of
mothers right these are things that help
explain the disparity in black north and
black maternal mortality rate okay with
all of that said Elizabeth Warren make
the common and obvious error of
mistaking all inequality for an
underlying structural inequities now
she's blaming health care professionals
this is just at the same time health
care professionals are putting their
lives on the line to save people black
white and green she's out there
suggesting that our health care system
is staffed by people who are inherently
racist the health care professionals
listen do they listen to black women and
why it is so important to raise this
issue because it's not like somebody
deliberately says oh you know I'm not
gonna pay attention it's that it's
happening and if you don't raise
awareness about it and get some
accountability in the system too many
people say well I didn't have anything
to do with that that's not me okay well
what if they didn't have anything to do
with that and it wasn't them I mean like
it's again the idea is that now you're
going to attribute all of the
inequalities in a system to current
people doing bad things that they don't
even know they are doing so now we are
ghost hunting right now we are we're
attributing motives to people that they
don't have themselves but deep in the
recesses of their brain they're still a
little racist and that is why you're
getting at these outcomes
I mean strange that that everything
amounts to the same it doesn't matter
what the what happens in front of the
equal sign is as a matter what the
equation is in front of the equal sign X
plus y always equals overthrow American
society and completely restructure it
it's pretty incredible it really is and
and it is a lot of this is also based on
you know political expedience a lot of
this is based on on the the easy belief
that your political opponents are evil
they don't have different priorities
from you they're actually evil so Rachel
Maddow tried to trap this one out last
night she suggested that conservatives
are operating from earth-2 when they
talk about people going back to work or
alternatively they have a different
assessment of the risks and benefits of
staying out of work as an entire society
and that assessment is different from
your own and that is called an honest
political disagreement but according to
her it's earth-2 and conservatives want
people to die I think this is just it's
just claptrap even in times this weird
conservative media is like earth-2 and
they are on a completely different
planet
in terms of what the news is and what it
means to cover it and the conservative
media is as influential as they ever
were if not more so when it comes to
Republican elected officials and
conservative voters in the Republican
party base but the conservative media
the most influential parts of it really
are living in and describing and now
promoting a completely different world
the one that all the rest of us live on
ok you know the one that the one that
you live on Rachel Maddow is one where
you are operating from a studio in
getting your salary paid that's the
world that you are living on right the
world that Chris Cuomo is living in
that's the world that everyone in CNN is
living in now all the members of the
media do not live the same lives at the
30 million people who are now unemployed
they do not live the same lives of the
small business owners who sunk their
life savings into a restaurant to watch
it disappear they are not living in the
same world as people who actually were
living on the bubble and now need to go
make a living they're not living the
same world as you this is why you end up
with with ridiculous comedian Patton
Oswalt tweeting out over the weekend
just you know we say that you'd
sacrifice you can always just sit home
and just watch Netflix no Patton Oswalt
can sit in his mansion and watch Netflix
they're a bunch of people whoever you
don't have a full fridge that's the
disconnect and by the way Democrats are
just full of it I mean here this is a
brutal ad so the RNC put out an ad about
Nancy Pelosi so I showed you a clip the
other day of Nancy Pelosi standing in
front of her very expensive fridge and
again I'm all for very expensive fridges
but I'm also for people being able to
work so that they can afford food in
their fridge apparently Nancy Pelosi is
not for that
so she's holding up funding for small
businesses and she's standing in front
this fridge talking about how it's
stocked with expensive gelato chocolate
ice cream and the RNC could this
viciously brutal ad it is perfectly
honest in it it does demonstrate the
disconnect you know about an earth -
this is an earth - you don't want to eat
up everything know it at one time I
can't do it much longer I'm trying so
hard can we say enjoying having to admit
that yeah we
and I like it better than anything else
taping this segment there are 22 million
people this specific program is about
stopping job losses today other people
and our family look for some other
flavors but I know it's survival mode
you don't know where that next something
knows about come from I don't know what
I would have done if I scream and not
invent it I just wondered brutal add and
then it says let them eat ice cream it
is a brutal ad me people are not eating
people are going to food bags people are
in line for food banks in Miami going
blocks at a time and we're pretending
this is you know as Don Lemon says just
people who want to go out and get
haircuts really that that's what's going
on here speaking of people who are
completely disconnected Bill DeBlasio
continues to be a complete tool bag of
stupidity I mean my goodness Bill
DeBlasio groundhog murderer so Bill
DeBlasio today tweeted out there his
office tweeted up when this is all over
they want to hold a ticker tape parade
for health care workers now I'm all for
rewarding health care workers but a
ticker-tape parade sounds like a very
very bad idea that wasn't even his most
delusional comment of the last 36 hours
my favorite I did enjoy this I did enjoy
this is Bill de Blasio and New York
officials have decided that it is
worthwhile to release inmates from
Rikers Island it Rikers is the jail
facility and where people are being held
will be for trial and they decided we're
not gonna hold people right we're gonna
let criminals out and then it turns out
that some of those criminals wait for it
wait for it they are criminals and they
go in there perform crimes so bill de
blasio
suggests that he is just shocked by this
he says it in fact is unconscionable
that criminals are performing crimes
this may be the stupidest human being in
the United States and he lives within a
several block radius of the only
competitor ALC here is Bill DeBlasio
just being a communist my god bill
de blasio there would be you know a
rigorous monitoring effort as well and
that has been built up we do see some
recidivism I don't have the exact
numbers we see some I've not seen a huge
amount but any amount is obviously
troubling and I think it's
unconscionable just on a human level
that folks were shown mercy and this is
what some of them have done
but you know it's a small number of
people and you know it's troubling in
this unconscionable trouble and
troubling and unconscionable I mean I
just can't believe it it's troubling
that's what happens when you release
criminals from prison what yes bill de
blasio earth to build a block because
bill de blasio doesn't exist in the same
world as the records and rest of you
peons right he's walking in the park
with his wife though the blasio doesn't
live in your world bill the double
standard that applies to people in
positions of political and media power
it does allow them an enormous amount of
wiggle room when it comes to declaring
that everything is basically manageable
as current as it currently stands it is
not manageable as it currently stands
and this is why you have to
independently assess and everybody
should independently assess what are the
risk factors the risks and the world
rewards of the policies that we are
paying attention to and that is not an
easy answer and anybody who gives you an
easy answer we should open up right now
or we should close up right now what the
conditions are nobody has an easy answer
anyone who suggests an easy answer is
lying to you there is no easy answer
there is no answer that reduces the risk
to zero there is no answer that is going
to that is going to completely save the
economy in the absence of underlying
demand so take everything with a grain
of salt and I guess now we have to
examine the motives of our public
policymakers because they're making
fairly obvious that that many of them do
have in fact ulterior motives and are
disconnected from the worries of many
people in American society and that's
what's driving a lot of the political
unrest want to know how this became
political because for a lot of people it
never stopped being political already
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we will see you here
tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]